124 noms gravés dans la pierre
124 habitants du village de maillé le
plus jeune avait trois mois le plus âgé
89 ans mais ils sont tous morts le même
jour massacre et fusillé brûlé égorgé
une tragédie oubliée un mystère vieux de
soixante six ans sur lequel le voile se
lève
seulement aujourd'hui il tait tout ce
qu'ils voyaient même est arrivé rabattue
et tout ce qui bougeait puisque ils ont
tué dans les fermes les vaches des
chevaux les chiens c'était des sauvages
et nous chasser comme si j'achetais des
latins leur crise et s à 1 tiré sur
maman mon petit frère et ont coupé la
gorge comme vous arrive et que plus
personne
et plus personne plus maison plus rien
du tout se sait tout et est anéanti
nous sommes le 25 août 1944 le jour de
la libération de paris
au même moment dans un petit village de
touraine commence un des plus
effroyables massacres de civils de la
seconde guerre mondiale en france à
maillé en une matinée
des soldats allemands vont tuer la quasi
totalité des habitants du bourg des
vieillards des femmes et 44 enfants dont
plusieurs nourrissons assassiné jusque
dans leurs maisons
[Musique]
j'en sors n'en avait dix ans il se
trouvait chez lui avec sa mère et ses
huit frères et soeurs quand les soldats
allemands sont arrivés tous les
habitants sont un par un certains
parents ma mère a dit et quand vous êtes
en train de monter une arme là c'est
pour nous un par un par un à l'air
dégoûté sur place avec mes enfants a dit
jeudi que mes enfants la bomba ils ont
parlementé un moment parce que enfin un
moment ça m'a paru long parce que moi
j'étais présent j'étais avec ma mère
justement dans cette pièce d'avis qu'on
avait là qui servait de cuisine salle à
rouler tout est alors a dit vincent d'un
sacré doux sur place parce qu'on sait ce
qui nous attend
la famille aura la vie sauve mais le
père lui sera fusillé gisèle bourgoin
était caché dans la cave avec ses frères
et soeur et sa mère
dans la famille maman étant la plus
jeune de dix et tous ses frères et seat
à surveiller c'est pourquoi nous avons
perdu 17 personnes
un grand-père déon des plantes des
petits cousins deux en quatre ans six
ans c'est inoubliable et plus on lit
plus on y pense plus et c'est une
épreuve
le jour du drame serge martin était chez
ses grands parents à quelques kilomètres
de maillé il sera l'unique survivant
voulais pas le savoir j'y croyais pas
dans la tête d'un gamin de 10 ans c'est
pas facile à croire
enfin même dans la tête d'autres
personnes mais moi dans ma tête à moi je
voulais pas le croire je disais non
c'est pas possible c'est pas vrai et
puis c'est resté comme ça et personne
n'en parlait personne absolument
personne
je vous qui fait que coûte quelques
jours quand même j'ai voulu revenir chez
moi j'ai demandé à rené et puis et c'est
là qu'ils m'ont dit que personne que
tout était détruit et j'y suis remonte
ma ma compagne et je suis redescendu à
mayer morissette charpentier avait neuf
ans ses frères et sa mère ont été tués
sous ses yeux
[Musique]
j'ai entendu un coup de fusil alors là
je suis est ce que eux entendus mamans
savent et appeler ou créer je n'en sais
rien mais sont revenus sur elle et l'ont
tué ils ont tué à bout portant
moi je suis revenu je suis revenu à moi
et je l'appelais j'ai dû lui parler je
lui ai dit je sais pas ce que je peux
lui dire je n'en sais rien mais elle m'a
santé auprès d'elle puisque el mahdi 20
20 ans ma petite morissette ils vont te
tuer toi aussi et moi c'est fini à laver
sa main là sur son coeur où elle avait
été sa poitrine
c'était et elle m'a dit pour moi c'est
fini et ça a été fini alors j'ai compris
bien sûr qu'elle était morte alors chez
les coureurs et coureuses
non
des événements de maillé personne ou
presque on entendra parler de gaulle
choisit de faire des ruines d'oradour
sur glane le symbole de la barbarie
nazie en france
le village de maillé entièrement
incendié et détruit par les allemands et
reconstruit à l'identique mais deux
questions restent sans réponse qui est
pourquoi à l'institut d'histoire du
temps présent
henry rousso travaille depuis longtemps
sur la barbarie nazie
si on essaie de rationaliser ou de
réduire salido légion ne comprend pas il
ya un élément qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que ceux qui tirent sont persuadés
que l'enfant dans le bras de sa mère est
un ennemi l'allemagne ça nous paraît
complètement fou et paranoïaque et tout
ce qu'on veut mais c'est une des clés
pour comprendre la violence nazie et
cette violence là qui s'est déployée
encore une fois pendant quatre ans cinq
ans alès s'est appliqué à jour deux
jours avec oradour émaillaient en france
fin août 44 les alliés progresse vers
l'est tandis que les troupes allemandes
se replient vers le nord en longeant la
loire
mallet est un village anonyme de
touraine proche de la ligne de
démarcation et de deux voies de
communication de première importance la
nationale 10 et la voie ferrée paris
bordeaux un terrain d'action idéal pour
la résistance
le général berger avait 19 ans il
faisait partie d'un des trois mâts qui
installés autour de maillé l'élément
déclencheur du massacre de maillé
c'était une action d'un élément des
forces françaises de l'intérieur d'un
maquis qui le 24 août en fin
d'après-midi se trouvait dans une ferme
située à 2 km au nord nord d'ace de mou
des maillets et qui a pris à partie deux
voitures dans le monde
venant de
sainte maure et se dirigeant surveillée
et ses deux voitures sont passées à
proximité de la ferme dans laquelle se
trouvaient les maquisards qui ont ouvert
le feu ils ont blessé tu es un certain
nombre d'allemands 1 2
le massacre qui apparaît clairement
comme une action de représailles est un
fardeau trop lourd à porter pour la
résistance au point que l'ema qui vont
faire disparaître les traces écrites des
actions effectuées près du village la
veille du massacre les maquis vont se
reprocher les uns les autres
les différentes actions qui ont été
faites à proximité de manière alors que
chaque maquis ils ont tous opérés des
actions à proximité de villages ça
pouvait pas être autrement les
villageois sont quand même assez serré
donc s'ils voulaient obéir aux ordres
c'est à dire retarder le départ des
troupes allemandes il fallait bien
qu'ils fassent en action certains
endroits ils pouvaient pas toujours le
fermement au même endroit qui est obligé
de faire des embuscades il obéissait aux
ordres mais ça n'excuse par une action
qui a été fait par les allemands de fait
la stratégie allemande en matière de
représailles sur le front de l'ouest
change au début de l'année 1944 les
ordres du haut commandement sont sans
équivoque
comme l'expliquent l'historienne
autrichiennes barbara l'an bauer je
pense notamment aux décrets de chevet
relais qui était donc de février 1944 il
disait que lorsqu'il ya attaque par les
mouvements de résistants il fallait tout
de suite riposté
même lorsque ça concerne des villages
même lorsque ça concerne la population
dans les villages innocent qu'il fallait
tirer dessus qu'il fallait brûler des
maisons et sur tout ce qui était à punir
ce n'est pas quand ça allait au delà des
objectifs ces violences mais lorsqu'il y
avait un commandant qui renonçaient à
punir quand il y avait un commandant qui
était trop timide pour ainsi dire danser
dans ses pratiques
pendant près de soixante ans les
survivants du massacre se taisent
pourtant en 2004
tout va basculer aux archives
municipales de tours
deux policiers et un procureur allemand
fouilles dans les rapports de la gestapo
ils sont à la recherche d'un disque qui
leur permettrait de retrouver les
soldats responsables de la tuerie
informé par hasard de l'existence du
drame de mailler le procureur spécial de
dortmund ulrich maass s'est emparé de la
faire ce magistrat est chargée de
poursuivre les nazis coupable de crimes
de guerre pour les traduire devant la
justice allemande à maillé le
déroulement des événements de mailler le
fait d'avoir tué plus de 40 enfants et
des femmes me permet de dire que le
critère d'atrocités rempli correspond à
ce que notre loi classe sous la
catégorie des moeurs imprescriptible le
meurtre en tant que crimes de guerre
n'est pas prescrit en allemagne je peux
et je dois au regard de la loi
poursuivre à piloter fléchi depuis 30
ans l'allemagne a obtenu le droit de
rouvrir des enquêtes concernant la
seconde guerre mondiale contrairement à
la france qui n'a pas ratifié la
convention internationale sur les crimes
de guerre
cette convention a été signée en 1968
donc une convention internationale
on est six ans après la guerre d'algérie
si la france signe l'imprescriptibilité
des crimes de guerre à ce moment là elle
peut avoir le risque de voir des
officiers français qui ont être qu'ils
ont commis des crimes de guerre ou qui
peuvent être soupçonnées d'avoir commis
des crimes de guerre et y en a eu
évidemment en algérie poursuivi sur un
plan sur la base de crimes de guerre
pour mailler les allemands sont partis
d'un dossier quasiment vide
du massacre il reste deux bouts de
papier conservés aux archives de tours
avec ce message c'est la punition des
terroristes et de leurs assistants
il s'agit des deux seules manuscrits
qu'on ait trouvé sur le lieu du massacre
à maillé manuscrit écrit au crayon de
bois par deux mains différentes
semble-t-il dont l'un avait sans doute
été plantés dans un des cas dames c'est
un détail un peu macabre mais bon et ça
a été ramassé par les gendarmes qui ont
fait le premier constat et qui ont donc
transmis un premier rapport de
gendarmerie qui accueille donc le
premier document officiel si l'on peut
dire qu'il relate le massacre de maillé
ce rapport de gendarmerie est bâclée
aucune douille de munitions ramasser
aucun indice qui permettrait
d'identifier les coupables
le sous-lieutenant de la wehrmacht
gustav schlüter qui a ordonné cette
action de représailles a bien été
condamné par contumace à bordeaux en
1952 mais il est mort chez lui en
allemagne sans avoir été interrogé ni
inquiétés aujourd'hui on s'indigne qu'on
est jugé par contumace à le responsable
d'un massacre bon d'ampleur un maillet
le chef de la ss en france le chef de la
ss en france en france carl aubert a été
libéré de prison par général de gaulle
en 1962 donc il faut encore une fois se
replacer à une banalité d'historiens
dans le contexte de l'époque c'était le
prix à payer pour la réconciliation
franco allemande
les allemands ont décidé de faire face à
leur passé depuis les années 70 les
procédures se sont multipliées avec
l'ouverture progressive des archives de
guerre dans la banlieue de stuttgart
un discret bâtiment abrite l'unité
spéciale de policiers chargés de traquer
les criminels de guerre nazis dans les
couloirs sont exposés les insignes des
soldats du 3e reich
quelle marque de distinction qu'elle un
signe nous double savoir faire la
différence selon les descriptions des
témoins pour savoir si une personne
appartient à la wehrmacht oss c'est
important aussi de connaître l'endroit
où est placée l'insigne pour connaître
le graet le connaisseur schnyder est
chargée de l'enquêté
sa seule arme le papier 44 classeur noir
rempli c'est une armoire entière de son
bureau car l'administration nazie
consigne est où les policiers ont
identifié trois mille huit cents soldats
présents cette époque dans la région 370
sont encore en vie et 170 ont été
interrogés mais dès qu'il s'agit de
mailler les réponses se font très
évasive
nous contactons tout ce que nous avons
identifiés comme témoin nous faisons
vraiment le maximum
ce n'est pas toujours facile il y à des
documents qui manquent et d'autres qui
ne sont pas comblés à l'office de
renseignements de la wehrmacht ses
cheveux c'est très compliqué de
retrouver les personnes qui étaient sur
place de savoir si elles sont encore
vivantes et si on veut leur part le
président
le travail est gigantesque mais le
procureur ulrich maass ne se décourage
pas il est maintenant convaincu que de
très jeunes soldats de la dix septième
division de la waffen ss ont participé
au massacre
une division qui se repliaient en 44
après avoir subi de lourdes pertes
pendant la bataille de normandie
elle avait l'ordre de retarder l'avancée
des alliés
ils disaient les stocks dans cette liste
vous trouvez des soldats et policiers
qui étaient stationnées à châtellerault
amsa c'est prouvé et nous sommes sûrs
que quelques-uns se trouvaient présents
à malley nous allons contrôler encore
une fois tous ceux qui ont survécu à la
guerre
voyez ça c'est une trace unique traces
ulrich maas a déjà à son actif quatre
procès impliquant des criminels de
guerre nazis et il a géré une dizaine d'
enquête à travers toute l'europe
derrière lui la collection entière des
comptes rendus du procès de nuremberg
il n'a à l'époque du nazisme à l'époque
de la guerre nous les allemands nous
sommes chargés d'une telle culpabilité
que l'on ne doit pas prescrire c'est
correct
c'est incontournable sur le plan
juridique main politique et morale bien
sûr nous avons le devoir et je ressens
comme mon devoir personnel de rechercher
de découvrir la vérité même après 30 ans
aller jusqu'aux derniers survivants
trouver ce qu'il est encore possible de
trouver au jeu
cet été ulrich maass est parti à la
retraite sans rassembler tous les
morceaux du puzzle
son successeur veut encore croire à la
probabilité d'un procès une mission qui
résonne en écho au poids de la
culpabilité porté par la génération
d'après-guerre à maillé l'enquète
allemandes à aider à libérer la parole
après 60 ans de silence
moi avec papa et papa avec mois et
l'entourage mes tantes et tout on
voulait pas faire de la peine on voulait
pas faire de la peine à voulait pas se
faire de l'appel
réciproquement je pense que si ça c'est
pas notre âge notre génération qui n'a
pas parlé
c'est la génération d'avant nous que ce
nous nous étions comme beaucoup d'autres
on était enfant alors si les générations
d'avant nous on a parlé pas nouvelle on
a continué pareils et on n'avait pas
envie et puis je crois que il n'avait
pas envie d'en parler parce que c'est à
dire que c'était tellement horrible que
et il pensait que les gens ne pas les
croire le 25 où se retrouvaient tous les
copains d'école enfin les copains
d'école ce qui est des rescapés comme
nous qui qui venait la cérémonie ont
parlé d' avant on parlait d'après mais
jamais on parlait de cette journée là
jamais on en a parlé entre nous jamais
jamais je ne sais pas pourquoi c'est que
maintenant qu'on peut arriver
à parler mais c'est dur le bail
croyez-moi des victimes comme
emprisonnées dans leurs souvenirs comme
l'expliquent la psychanalyste claude
halmos spécialiste des traumatismes de
l'enfance parler mais avant même de
parler se souvenir mettre des mots pour
soi sachant que ce qu'on a vécu c'est
innommable
c'est pas cernable veut dire quelqu'un
qui vient qui égorgent un enfant devant
vous on peut toujours dire les mots mais
d'avant les mots ils sont on peut même
pas les dire mais mais c'est innommable
donc pour arriver à aa a énoncé c'est
moi penser la chose avant même de la dir
il faut repasser par l'horreur est
repassé par l'horreur c'est à dire que
les émotions sont bloqués pour survivre
il a fallu ne pas se souvenir de
l'horreur dans laquelle on a été quatre
ans après l'ouverture de l'enquète par
l'allemagne la france par la voix du
chef de l'état reconnaît enfin à mailler
le statut de village martyr
[Musique]
en ignorant si longtemps le drame de
maillet en restant indifférente à la
douleur des survivants
en laissant s'effacer de sa mémoire le
souvenir des victimes
la france a commis une faute morale
c'est cette faute qu'au nom de la nation
toute entière
je suis venu reconnaître réparé
aujourd'hui tout au long de son enquête
le procureur ulrich maass est revenu à
maillé pour informer les habitants une
enquête qui a mobilisé la presse
française et internationale
pourtant les chances de traduire un jour
les coupables du massacre devant la
justice sont quasiment nulles
mais pour les survivants et les familles
des victimes
l'essentiel est ailleurs
il ya un pas de fait c'est qu'on connaît
les troupes parce qu'on ne connaissait
pas les troupes qu'ils avaient fait ça
maintenant on connaît les les troupes
qui l'ont fait mais maintenant nous ce
qu'on attend c'est de savoir pourquoi
ils ont fait ça et essayer si elle une
justification il ya quelque chose qui
pour quoi ils envers les recherches
vis-à-vis de larges que les personnes
pourraient avoir maintenant bon c'est
bien de connaître si on peut connaître
la vérité mais pour nous elle changera
pas notre ce qu'on a vu ce qu'on a
entendu on oublie pas en ouvrant une
enquête
l'allemagne espère régler ses comptes
pour les générations futures
une démarche qui permet aussi aux
victimes de maillet et à leurs
descendants de commencer enfin un
travail de deuil pour leur histoire je
vous dis il préférait quand même dire
c'était l'unité ses portes ce pas tout
la mam hollande c'est une unité spéciale
que ses camarades auront là or ils ont
certainement essayer de savoir qui
aurait fait le coup et pourquoi et quel
résumons nous on avait atteint pendant
jours
c'est la seule chose c'est qu'on parle
de loups enfin c'est une façon de rendre
justice aux victimes qui avaient été un
peu passé à l'oubli sous silence pas
dans le village de maillé même mais au
niveau national et en général dans
l'historiographie
on connaissait on savait très peu de
choses sur mallet et donc je pense que
même quand c'est tardivement c'est une
façon quand même de d'encore indiqué que
le dernier mot n'est pas n'ai pas dis
même pas lorsque le responsable sont
morts parce que qui dit qu'il y en a
encore qui est vive mais que quand même
on n'oublie pas ce genre de choses dans
ce sens là je me félicite plutôt qui a
pas de prescription de ce genre de crime
et qu'on puisse le poursuivre à côté de
l'enquète il y a le poids du non dit
même si les victimes de traumatisme ne
parle pas quelque chose s'est inscrit
dans leur mémoire et se transmet aux
générations suivantes le travail à faire
c'est de faire que on en face de la vie
et au lieu d'en faire de la mort est la
meilleure façon d'en faire de la vie ces
bleus parler c'est d'expliquer aux
générations suivantes ce qui sait ce qui
s'est passé de leur permettre de
travailler sans rapprochant d'autres
massacres de tout ce que ben et surtout
en comprenant qu'il ya quelque chose à
faire parce que quand même des histoires
comme ça ça nous pose le problème de des
gens qui ont fait ça de pourquoi dans
l'histoire il s'est passé des
monstruosités semblables et pas
seulement avec les nazis un le rwanda
c'est pas mieux enfin je veux dire c'est
la même passé la même sauvagerie la même
horreur pour les gens qui l'ont vécue
donc il faut aussi donner aux
générations suivantes l'idée qu'on peut
se battre contre ça il s'agit pas de
rêver d'un monde idéal où ça
n'arriverait plus il s'agit de dire on
peut faire des choses pour se battre et
c'est ça qui fait qu'on est du côté de
la vie la procédure judiciaire s'est
ajoutée à la bataille pour la mémoire
une bataille qui avait commencé avec le
projet de construire dans le village une
maison du souvenir
quand est-ce qu'on a commencé à en
parler au bout de cinquante ans pour le
50e anniversaire
les survivants du massacre ont porté ce
projet à bout de bras comme pour combler
le silence qui les alliés pendant si
longtemps
la maison du souvenir accueille
aujourd'hui des collégiens et des
lycéens
et ce sont ces mêmes survivants qui sont
là pour raconter leur propre histoire
c'est le
c'est très très dur pour nous après de
continuer à en parler mais si on l'a
fait quand vous avez vu je suis très
émotive je suis très touché mais si on
l'a tous fait d'en parler
et si on continue à chaque groupe
scolaire de venir témoigner
c'est par respect pour ceux qui sont
partis au penser qu'ils ont perdu la vie
[Musique]
ç'a changé ma vie complètement quoi
particules bon je vais rester tout seul
à 10 ans j'ai vécu avec ça ils ont que
j'ai vécu parce que la vie c'est quelque
chose d'important mais on vit pas comme
les autres on vit avec sa
continuellement
[Musique]